know how people will react to it but
what do you think you want to convey in
some way
you say people don't want to live this
life i understand
but you want to convey some
some kind of
sense of what this extremely
complex life was about i've never
understand the concept
how do i ex how do i express this
i've never expressed this but how do i
start
i've never um
i'm never um i was never
able um to understand the concept of
greatness
i just never was able to understand that
concept of greatness
and um as time went on and i've
gotten older and i've um i've
met many journeys on people that i met
on my journey
and people who i've read about on my
journey i read that um
all greatness the majority of greatness
in itself doesn't come with goodness the
two don't coexist with one another
and i spent all my life trying to become
great because i had such a low
self-esteem
and um and i realized um late in life
on sam47 but late in my life
that um all great men are not good men
and then so i try to embark on a whole
different career and try to become good
but what's the concept of good being a
um a floor mat i never understood the
concept of good
the concept of good is pretty much then
i must be a politician because
politicians always striking for goodness
and always trying to win votes from
people and only only reason that we win
votes because they believe that we're
good
so how do we live in those two
dimensions at once you want that
greatness for self
gratification but you want goodness from
a human perspective
and i and i i really have no idea no
clue how do i um
how do i juggle both of them and be in
harmony
and then in all actuality they don't
exist you have to pick a side
what are the qualities you admire in
people
yes um desire
i i respect the person who's willing to
die for what he truly wants
even if it's love even if it's a woman
whatever is it that he truly believes in
and that they believe that he he um it
transcends him to that um
that level to um demand them
for lovely since for instance um i look
at love as a
command to just rise to your greatest
potential
you know and um that's how people should
feel
the objective should be to rise to their
best potential in life
if it's to lose 30 pounds if it's to
pass a test
it should be um to win a fight
to be um to be admired by people all
over the world
it should allow you to rate rise to your
greatest potential
that you look at yourself in the most
grandest fashion
i'd like to take a moment here to
to say that this book is a